[Music]
what do we want
[Music]
control
it's no secret that we're here because
we would like to control our thoughts
i can't promise you that
most of what you think is a habit you're
only thinking it because you thought it
before
according to some researchers up to 98
of our thoughts are exactly the same
ones we had yesterday
and about 70 to 80 of them tend to be
negative
this is because when we're awake and
we're not doing anything in particular
the resting state of the brain is
constantly tracking our body and
environment for potential threats
this is referred to as our default
network
we can't control the negative habitual
thoughts that just pop in her head
try this experience with me
let's sit
silently for one minute
don't think about anything
you probably didn't make it through five
seconds without a thought like
is this the lecture
why isn't she talking
how long is this lecture going to be
we can't control the thoughts that arise
automatically
we can't turn off our default network
but we do have the ability to interrupt
the cascade of thoughts that come after
that first thought
we can change the learned associations
that accompany our thoughts and prevent
ourselves from asking endless follow-up
questions to that first thought like
what if or why
for example the first thought may be
i have no idea how i'm going to handle
getting through all my work obligations
next week and have time for the parent
teacher zoom meetings
that thought pops into your head
not under your control
but that first thought is then followed
by a second a third and a fourth
what if i don't get the project done for
the staff meeting
why are the school meetings this week it
seems like every other year they are a
bit later in the semester
maybe i have it wrong
what if i end up having to take the dog
to the vet again and i'm going to have
to make a choice between taking time off
for the dog or taking time off for my
kids
it's the cascade of thoughts afterward
that feels overwhelming and can turn
into overthinking
in lecture one i introduced the
paradoxical psychology of overthinking
the paradox is that in order to get away
from unwanted thoughts
we have to move towards them
in the moment of that first thought
i have no idea how i'm going to handle
getting through all my work obligations
this week
it's only by turning towards and
consciously responding to that thought
differently that we can moderate how
much that thought will affect us
just imagine as your head is hitting the
pillow at night and that nagging thought
pops into your head i didn't get done
what i wanted to get done today
and then that's it period eyes closed
you fall asleep
it sounds strange to describe it this
way because we're so used to that first
thought leading to another and another
when we worry about what we didn't get
done it's almost automatic that we start
thinking about what wasn't done and stop
worrying with what if and why questions
but we can move in the direction of
interrupting that negative train of
thought
buddhist philosophy describes the
process of interrupting this habitual
cascade of thoughts
as stopping the second dart
a more mainstream philosophy you may
have seen on a bumper sticker reflecting
the idea is
pain is inevitable but suffering
is optional
pain is the first dart
we can't avoid it no matter what we do
in this world we'll encounter pain
inescapable physical or mental
discomfort
we'll encounter thoughts that we do not
want that are not under our control
like i didn't get done what i wanted to
do today
suffering is the second dart
these are the darts that we throw at
ourselves
the amount of suffering we experience
the amount of overthinking that we do
depends on our reaction to the original
pain the original thought
these are the thoughts we have about our
thoughts
and these follow-up thoughts
we have some control over
it's our reactivity that throws the
second third fourth and fifth darts
typical second darts include
overreacting to little things
holding grudges
dwelling on what happened in the past
worrying about things you can't control
and mentally rehashing conversations
asking what if
asking
why
in the situation where you thought you'd
not gotten enough done today
you might then add on being irritated
with the unexpected phone calls that
took up your extra time
remembering another time that you'd not
finished what you set out to do and how
it made your entire week difficult
worrying that the internet might go out
in the storm tomorrow and what if you
can't put the extra time in that you'd
planned
i think you get the idea
second darts vastly outnumber first
darts
there are enough challenges in life
without adding more
but it's the habit of our mind to add on
and it's the habit of our mind to think
that this thinking habit is impossible
to change
but remember our new attitude is to move
towards our thoughts
and this can feel easier when we take
the perspective
that our thoughts are just like any
other experience we're having
our ears hear
our intestines digest
our brains
think
there's not necessarily anything special
in the content of our thoughts
our brain is doing its job
we can give it different job
requirements
we can interrupt this habit
it is something we can change
the way to interrupt it is to turn
toward our habit of adding on
pay attention to it
these second darts can be interrupted by
mindfulness practice and by paying
attention to our thoughts and experience
differently
let's practice interrupting the darts
that we throw at ourselves
we'll begin by simply stepping back and
taking a good look at whatever's in
front of us
turning towards what comes to our
attention
and then observing and describing it
this process is referred to as
objectification
where we step back and see each element
of an experience as an object in our
internal environment
just as if we could pick up everything
we sense in our hands
observe it
describe it
in a more real world example
i could be looking at a bank statement
while i'm looking at it i could take a
step back
seeing numbers
a piece of paper
noticing that i'm thinking of thought
that i made poor choices last month
feeling my heart beat faster
these are elements of objectification
this isn't our usual way of going about
things
typically we simply get lost in the
experience and allow the cascade of
habitual thoughts to just flow rapidly
by us
instead of knowing clearly what we're
seeing thinking and feeling
naturally as soon as the thought arises
that maybe i made poor choices last
month
i may begin adding on
being resentful of my kids asking me to
take them to the mall
rehashing a conversation with my
accountant
worrying about the cost of tuition next
semester
and the add-ons keep accumulating
we don't have control over the current
state
in this moment of the bank account
it is what it is
but we may want it to be or have a goal
that it be different than it is
and we do have some influence over the
unnecessary cascade of thoughts
generated from the situation
anything that enters your experience can
be objectified
you can call it what it is and literally
name it to tame it
most objectification mindfulness
practices
are simply giving names to experiences
they are labeling exercises
we'll begin our practice at a very
general level
labeling what are referred to in
buddhist philosophy as sense doors
the idea is
any experience you can have can be
placed in one of the categories of your
senses if you include thinking
as a sense
in buddhist philosophy thinking is
described as a sense just like hearing
or seeing
in this practice we're not trying to get
rid of anything
we aren't trying to stop our ears from
hearing our eyes from seeing
or our minds from thinking
we're simply identifying what is
happening in order to interrupt the
habitual way that we string objects in
our experience together
within this exercise the possible labels
that we'll incorporate are the senses
plus
thinking
feeling
hearing
seeing
smelling tasting
and thinking
smell and taste are lumped into one
category because they're so challenging
to fully separate
so during this exercise
i may notice the pulsing of my heart and
say
feeling
and then notice the sound of the wind
against the window and label that
hearing
and then i find myself analyzing whether
i'm paying more attention to the feeling
of my seat or the sound of a dog barking
and i'm not sure
and i label that
thinking
we're going to do this exercise together
out loud
i'll check in with my experience give it
a send store label out loud
and then i'll give you a moment
you check in with your experience and
give it a label out loud as well
we'll volley back and forth
watch and listen first as i simulate the
process
when i'm turned this way
i'm me
when i'm turned this way
i'm you
it'll sound like this
feeling
thinking
seeing
hearing
now let's do it together
sit in a way that you can lengthen up
through your spine
take a moment to feel into the sensation
of your breath
i'll check in with my experience and
give it a label out loud
and then you check in with yours and
give it a label out loud
we'll go back and forth for a few
minutes
feeling
seeing
thinking
thinking
feeling
hearing
feeling
thinking
feeling
seeing
tasting
hearing
seeing
thinking
feeling
feeling
thinking
feeling
thinking
hearing
feeling
now let's try the exercise silently
continue
internally at a calm pace
you don't need to label every single
event that happens simply notice and
label at a pace that doesn't create
anxiety
we'll be here for a couple more minutes
no matter how far away your mind wanders
you can always just label that reaction
as thinking
and begin again
slowly
open your eyes and drop the labeling
sense door labeling is the practice of
turning towards our thoughts
it interrupts the cascade of thinking
it helps us stop that second third or
fourth dirt
avoidance of our thoughts can bring
temporary relief which is one reason why
we have a tendency to push thoughts away
or turn away from them
but when we avoid nothing changes the
thinking comes back
when we turn towards we can create a new
pattern we can change the habit
why do we have this habit in the first
place
adding on to our thoughts in a way
that's not useful
because we're human
we all have this basic habit overthinker
or not
as human animals we're hardwired to move
towards things that we like
and move away from things that we don't
like
when something is pleasant we want more
of it
when you take your first crossfit class
and feel energized afterwards or maybe
just pleasantly sore like you achieved
something
you may start planning how you'll get
that feeling again
and when there are obstacles in your way
like your work schedule or parental
duties you may start brainstorming how
will you get around those things
we want it we work to move towards it
i mean just think of all the actions you
take when you meet someone that you like
and you want to move towards them
we put in the effort
on the flip side
as the human animals that we are if we
find something unpleasant
we want to get away from it avoid it and
we'll put in the effort to do so
say a co-worker calls you out on a
mistake at a staff meeting and you felt
embarrassed and worried about your
boss's reaction
when we have a difficult experience or
emotion we want to get away from it
so
later in the hallway you see that
co-worker coming you may decide to duck
into the next office in order to avoid
them all together
if we don't want something we work to
avoid it
what we want or don't want is not going
away our like and dislike reactions are
an automatic part of our survival system
our default network
and it's beyond our conscious control
our initial reaction is the first dart
better understanding of how this creates
a situation ripe for overthinking is
explained well by the control theory of
rumination
control theory describes overthinking as
problem solving gone wrong
thinking as problem solving begins from
a very logical reasonable likely obvious
place
we have evolved to be problem solving
animals and that's what our brain does
naturally for us all the time
we're hungry we figure out where food is
we have pain we figure out what's
hurting and how to avoid what caused
that
of course sometimes we need our minds to
work on more complex problems
like how to mend fences or avoid social
embarrassment with our co-worker
or
longer-term goals like how to keep
feeling good with crossfit
thinking as problem solving works when
we ask
how
and we can establish concrete actions to
move towards a goal or solve a problem
let's say we have a goal we want our
boss to give us a raise
control theory points out that the
thinking begins or is caused when we're
alerted to the fact that we've not
obtained a goal
say when your pay is deposited and you
notice that you would like the amount to
be higher
so we begin attempting to solve the
problem
we think
we brainstorm what's the best way to
approach the boss about getting a raise
we worry that our performance may not
have been up to par this year
we wonder what our colleagues are making
sometimes that thinking is useful
concrete action-specific planning works
thinking that leads you to setting up a
meeting with your boss
useful
thinking that leads you to making a list
of all the projects you led to create a
case for asking for a raise
useful
action-specific thinking works because
you can get answers and clearly assess
how much progress you're making towards
your goal
useful questions we ask
often start with
how
how will i meet my goal
these kinds of questions have concrete
answers and thinking about those answers
is actual problem solving
where problem solving goes wrong is when
you begin thinking about what if and why
these are not answerable questions on
our own because we can't know the future
or know why others think or do what they
do
speculating answers to these is not
solving a problem or are making progress
toward a goal
it's problem solving gone wrong so if
you spiral into questions like what if
my performance isn't meeting
expectations
what if my colleagues are all making
higher salaries than i am
why was jennifer given the bigger
project last month
in control theory
overthinking starts to take place
because we're aware that we're not
meeting the goal
or believe that not enough progress has
been made toward a goal we know there's
a problem but our thinking can't solve
it so we end up overthinking
unproductively
psychologists tested this idea directly
in 2013
they tested two groups on a number of
tasks after asking them to think about
an issue that had concerned them
the control group was asked to think
about a concern that had previously
troubled them but had been resolved
the experimental group was asked to
think about a concern that was an
unresolved issue
one that had repeatedly come into their
mind and caused them to feel negative or
stressed during the previous week
as predicted cueing unresolved goals
resulted in significantly greater
recurrent unwanted intrusive thoughts
than cueing resolved goals during
subsequent tasks
and the more any individual reported
overthinking in general in their lives
the more likely they were to be
influenced by that queuing
overthinking is not just triggered by
unresolved issues it becomes a habit
over time too
so let's think about it
within this model thinking about an
issue is not a problem
attempting to problem solve
is not a problem
the problem has to do with the goal
goals that are unresolved or hard to
make progress toward are likely to lead
to overthinking
we need to recognize that goals that are
impossible or are nearly impossible to
meet are going to be a problem
hence the question we need to ask
ourselves
is reaching my goal under my control
according to control theory if your goal
is something that is not under your
control or not something that you have
information about or could get clear
information on how to take steps towards
this can trigger overthinking
impossible goals
are more common than you might think
do any of these sound familiar
i want you to love my work
problem i don't have control over your
emotions
i want to be happy all the time
problem i can't control my mood all the
time
i don't want to think about my ex
problem i can't control the thoughts
that habitually pop into my
head we want things
we have these desires quickly
automatically out of habit and often out
of awareness
they cue thinking
and that can quickly cascade into
overthinking
the exercise that you worked with helps
with this reality
sense store labeling puts thinking on
the same level as anything else hearing
seeing smelling digesting
it makes the content of the thought goal
or otherwise not so important
it's just a thought
and turning towards these automatic
habitual thoughts can help us create a
new habit of interrupting the spiral
you may not have ever considered
what you want or what you don't want as
a goal that you're working toward
nor considered the reality that most of
what you want
is beyond your control
that's because the habit is ingrained
it started early
from the beginning of our lives we have
constantly tried to assess whether and
to what extent it's safe for us to try
and pursue goals
how we go about this became a habit
we quickly learn contingencies that we
detect in the world and if we had to
speak them they end up sounding a lot
like if then statements
if i cry
then my mother will come and soothe me
goal we want to be soothed the action we
take
crying
if i smile at my caregiver then they
will smile back at me
goal
we want affection
action
we smile at the person that we want
affection from
this pattern of understanding is
developed early during a childhood
period that's prone to
over-generalization
lack of experience
and the illusion that we can control how
another person responds to us
but in reality
we cannot control others
let's consider some if then statements
that reflect our actions as adults
if i make this person laugh
then they'll want to go out with me
goal we want someone to go out with us
problem
this is beyond our control
if i show that i have a plan for the
company's future in the staff meeting
then i will not get laid off
goal
i want to keep my job
problem
hiring and firing decisions are beyond
my control
we even have goals that attempt to
change the past
if i had worked less and spent more time
going on ski trips with my ex
we would still be together
problem
changing the past is not under our
control
again
we want something we begin thinking in
order to problem solve
but then one thought spirals into many
because it's cueing the fact that we've
not met our goal or have not made enough
progress towards it
this thinking is not problem-solving
it's overthinking
unfortunately
just understanding this cause of
overthinking doesn't make it go away
understanding in and of itself isn't
enough
we need to use what we understand to
figure out what action to take
we can re-pattern the habits of how we
think
for example using mindfulness exercises
like labeling sense doors that we began
with
we will also learn other techniques
including physical activities and
psychological tools that can help
but in the moment of overthinking at its
most basic
we can also just pause
pay attention to our thoughts
and ask ourselves a question
is there a problem that exists now
in the external world around you
if there is
can you do something to change it
now
if the answer is yes and yes
your thinking will be concrete problem
solving
go
solve the problem
but if the answer to even one of the
questions is no
then you're going to be likely to
overthink
we need to work with changing the habits
of how we think
that is what this course will help you
to do